hey guys I'm in New York I don't know if
I really want to even discuss with you
the process of getting here I didn't
wake up this morning almost instantly oh
thank you
I had Jenna and Edie and Bashar Leila
everybody calling and texting and saying
where are you just a with sleeping 20 17
guys it's still great right now we're
heading to a brand new app store have
you been here yet I have another nowhere
so I forgot so many things I brought an
apple charger I forgot a ton of
toiletries I basically had to pack my
bag in 15 minutes so I made it here for
this is my body I didn't wake up until 9
o'clock I got in an uber at 9:20 I had
to pack all my electronics I'm not sure
how I'm here today I got my coffee and
cranberry Brooke bar so sweet without
this hold on I'll continue my story but
first I gotta get I'm not booked on your
wow this is beautiful okay where's the
famous doesn't have it has been arranged
just a sec Michael checker we've got
some really bad news guys we are sold
out of them right now no loving 2017
that's my hashtag so right now we're
going to be heading to the Nintendo
switch launch dream so that's why we're
here in New York pretty excited do you
think you Nintendo for inviting me out
here for all of the fun so I cannot wait
so what are we going to find out tonight
are we going to learn everything about
it I think so I think we're find out
when it's coming out we're going to buy
the price and I find out I mean all that
really showed is that one video you
always true we saw Fallon but man that
video was so great I was like I see
myself in all of these situations I
don't in the backseat of a car oh yeah
and I see myself hanging out with my
Bros playing basketball and then I'm
like you know what this sucks
let's play on this which instead
oh my goodness which is a great pace let
me get so many friends so many that the
place is really cool I think I might
have to come back here and do some
shopping because why because I didn't
have time to pack anything nowhere
anymore
what's he nuts uh I don't know I gotta
go to the drugstore to you order it
because I forgot that it's level yeah
upstairs and downstairs the only saudi
upstairs
this lens doesn't have a zoom but trust
me it's there what if they take a pebble
or roller I think you text onto my phone
I landed again by using the Swiss law
state judges Rico hi first of all we
just sat there is Elysian into the
presentation
it comes out March 3rd 299 dollars enjoy
calm controller they have two different
versions there's one it's like the matte
black and then there's another version
to have a blue and a red we think I'm
getting around the blue won't get me to
it's pretty cause you know what really
goes briefing so maybe I'll get my black
and I don't make it all chrome you can
do that and then the straps come in
colors yeah so if you get the red the
blue though and you get colored straps
hello how's it going how are you oh my
god I just said bye was diagnosed you
ever here to see hello ELISA Michael on
because I run into a problem right start
recording I was on no idea was going to
be here but surprise we were
I know under any other social media
influencers
that's right I was like looking around
vd know that was on our place but I also
hear everybody what I say what do you
think I'm excited
March 3rd the first Mario game that
unless you're like Scullion like girl
showing in New York yeah Bobby it's not
like job is also every outfit everyone
wore in the video was amazing there are
no con you iron out what you guys like
are you dabbing or like what kind of
people you look they're like after the
51 like so good well whenever it comes
out we can have a party and we'll the
salsa oh my god this apparently will
usher have an icebreaker there we can
bring this everywhere oh I will I mean
that's true like it's like clearly at
night club it's like wow they people
playing video games night paper cover
and wait outside for 3 min okay I mean
that's better vibe that's what I want to
do that's what really I wish ya are in
our reality
well if I seen y'all came into a brass
on is actually Travis touchdown I didn't
realize you're actually trying to cut
down on Twitter - oh yeah that's a
that's a pg-13 account
I shared by a friend of mine and I'm but
I had started about 10 years ago when
when our final know right after I joined
Twitter I guess chord the morning oh my
god didn't say like hold on guys again
so much for vlogging Greg you're crazy
guys it's not too much don't go in there
too much do they know what they know
what you're dealing with right now no I
don't thinks I don't really talk about
it I just one lens even look good look
how wide it is do it and it's doing a -
it is great very sensor is part of it on
a be okay
okay that might get amazing though sorry
Alex
time to talk about your crazy volume
breaks yes
we're talking about what do you think
it's cool cool I think I'm really
excited actually see how like the
controllers work and how it all kind of
comes apart and everything but I tell
them like it doesn't look like but it
looks like it just kind of comes right
out and comes back together right I mean
maybe it's like magnetic or and it's
gotta be something like that like
MagSafe but yeah not written I can't
investigate like sorry you guys aren't
using it anymore so we will use it no
I'm really excited I called the Mario
game Odyssey yeah but dope is gonna be
around tomorrow anyway we're having a
great time here at the event yeah we're
in New York this is great yeah yeah two
thumbs up all right hey guys I just
wanted to a little vlog for you guys to
uh say hey we're here so I'm super
excited because I believe tomorrow I'm
going to actually get to play so
hopefully I'll be able to show you guys
some gameplay and some games and
actually get hands-on so look for that
video tomorrow make sure you guys leave
me some comments below and let me know
what you think of incidents and what
games you looking forward to tell me all
of the things I'll see you later hey
guys Justine and surprised this title of
this video it's actually not quickly for
one come on I'm actually that bad of a
click Vader
you know there's far worse at least when
I click bait you in times I'm nice
enough to at least put in the
description at what time code I'm
actually talking about said thing last
year I titled several videos new hair